was geht hier ist eine max und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem video ich wollte
heute einfach mal ein bisschen reden
über schule abi und sonst war 2 ich
mache gerade mein abi und das ist so
ziemlich alles was mich zur zeit
beschäftigt weil ich ziemliche angst vor
meinem erzfeind dem mathe abi habe
deshalb habe ich euch gesagt schreiben
doch mal fragen auf twitter zur schule
abitur oder sonstwas und ich beantworte
die also bei mir ist es so ich bin schon
immer jemand der wenig für die schule
gemacht hat mich irgendwie war ich
besonders cool finde oder sowas sondern
weil ich irgendwann damit angefangen
habe und einfach nicht mehr rausgekommen
bin weil irgendwann befindest du dich
also ein teufelskreis und willst nichts
mehr machen und vorab schon mal es ist
immer besser ist zu machen wenn man sich
denkt oh [ __ ] jetzt bin ich schon so ein
teufelskreis jetzt kann ich eh nichts
mehr machen ist es immer besser dann
anzufangen als ein tag später weil ich
habe jetzt noch zwei wochen bis zu
meinem mathe abi und ich bin ziemlich
aufgeschmissen muss ich sagen weil ich
das echt schrecklich finde und mir halt
immer gedacht okay du bist so schlecht
dass er nicht sehen
aber jetzt muss ich was machen auf
teufel komm raus weil jetzt kommt es
drauf an
und jetzt ist es halt viel mehr als wenn
ich mir gedacht hätte ok jetzt mal ich
halt mal irgendwas auch wenn ich denke
ich kann eigentlich nichts also
vielleicht könnt ihr euch auch ein
bisschen was davon mitnehmen
andererseits ist vielleicht auch noch
irgendwie sich jetzt gelaber über die
schule anzuhören und irgendwelche pseudo
motivation zu reden weil ihr heute aus
der schule kommt und sowieso keinen bock
darauf habt ja ja ich weiß nicht ihr
können über die kommentare schreiben
ist es doof wenn jemand über schule
redet oder ist das in ordnung
jetzt fangen wir mal mit den fragen news
ehefrau fragt bist du gut in der schule
und kannst du dich beim lernen lange
konzentrieren gut in der schule ja kann
man sagen also ich habe aktuell 2,4 aber
ich habe halt einerseits fächer in dem
ich richtig gut bin aber auf der anderen
seite gibt es halt auch fächer sowie
matte zum beispiel wo ich echt schlecht
bin
also das ist vor allem mathe sonst bin
ich halt in keinem fall richtig schlecht
oder so aber in mathe komme ich oftmals
nicht über keine ahnung 34 punkten weg
oder sowas
das entspricht halten 5 und insgesamt
bin ich schon eher sagen dass ich ganz
gut bin
hast du angst dein abi nicht zu schaffen
ja ich habe ein bisschen angst mache zum
beispiel komplett in den sand zu setzen
dann gibt es zwar immer noch die chance
nach prüfung zu machen bisschen angst
habe ich schon es ist immer so von
fakten schaffe ich niemals bis 8 sonst
machst du die nachprüfungen schaffst das
dann halt es wechselt sich irgendwie so
ab und mega bulle ist schon scheiße oder
modern warfare luft müssen kann man so
nicht sagen ich bin schule hat schon
einige coole aspekte einerseits du
kannst halt hart film soll im vergleich
zu späteren lebensphasen andererseits
lernst du teilweise echt coole dinge und
kannst auch spaß haben
aber es gibt halt einige elemente die
schule zur hölle machen können wenn du
jetzt zum beispiel irgendwie na ja
einfach hast was du hast lehrer hast mit
ihm überhaupt nicht klar kommst oder
wenn mitschüler hast mit dem du nicht
klar kommst dann kann schule schon echt
relativ schnell relativ scheiße werden
in dem sinne sollte man es nicht dazu
kommen lassen aber das haben mir die
leute auch schon gesagt bevor ich zum
beispiel in mathe probleme entwickelt
habe also probiert schlauer zu sein als
ich aber falls es nicht schafft habe ich
auch nicht bevorzugst du mündliche oder
schriftliche prüfungen definitiv
mündliche also ich bin so jemand der
klar man kann also auch nicht nur labern
sondern ich kann auch relativ gut
inhalte strukturieren wenn ich mündlich
vortragen und ganz kurze anekdote
letztens in sozialkunde ein referat
halten müssen ich hab das heißt in der
stunde davor während des unterrichts
gemacht weil ich zu hause nicht fertig
gemacht habe
dabei noch 14 punkte war es eine glatte
eins ist bekommen und dementsprechend
mündlich mündlich mündlich hätte ich
nicht so geschrieben werde ich
wahrscheinlich irgendwie vier punkte
oder sowas bekommen aber mündlich
vorträge auch abfragen sind immer besser
als schriftlich eigentlich hast du four
nach seinem abitur zu studieren wenn ja
was fragezeichen
gute frage ich weiß noch nicht genau was
ich halte es für grundsätzlich sinnvoll
sich weiter zu qualifizieren
aber ich habs nur zwei richtung in die
ich mich entwickeln würden wollte wo ich
mir vorstellen kann und da gucke ich
einfach wenn ich tatsächlich freie zeit
habe beschäftige ich mich mit den sachen
und guckt was gefällt dir besser und
dann mach ich das was ist dein traum
durchschnitt für das abi also da ich
halt eigentlich keine großen nc fächer
habe die mich interessieren also ncs
clausus ist hätten bestimmte
durchschnitt die man braucht um manches
zu studieren da ich das nicht habe keine
ahnung wenn sich so ein 22 schnitt oder
so was irgendwie sowas voll cool ich
würde sagen sie machen zum schluss noch
ein fragen der vita siehst du jetzt nach
dem abi nach köln habe ich vor
ich weiß nicht wie lange ob ich das nun
mal zum anschauen mache oder sowas
aber es gibt da einige projekte die mich
vielleicht nach köln ziehen bist du mit
deinen abi fältchen zufrieden ja bis auf
mathe wenn ich mal aussprechen würde
wäre ich der glücklichste mensch der
welt
aber das geht leider bei uns in bayern
nicht meistens so bis 13.15 ansonsten
als zweimal ursprünglich bis ich glaube
17 uhr 15 deine tipps für referate sich
so gut vorbereiten dass man eh nicht
komplett verpacken kann und sich dann
denke ich kein vorbild verpacken dann
trage ich jetzt ganz locker fahren was
in einer abi fächer deutsch mathe
italienisch englisch wirtschaft habt ihr
auch eine motto woche an der schule wenn
ja welches war ein lieblingsthema neben
leider keine mottowoche solche coolen
traditionen haben wir hier nicht
aber ich bin immer lustig ja sollte
damals dass man heute schon lästig oder
nicht kann aber ihr wisst am besten
und immerhin gab es mal wieder video
macht's gut